- [Voiceover] Hey grammarians,
let's talk about prepositional phrases:
what they are, and how they're used.
Their care and feeding, you know.
So a prepositional
phrase, simply speaking,
is anything that follows
a preposition, frankly.
So, if we look at the sentence:
Danielle blew the horn with
the strength of a giant-
quick little doodle there.
There's Danielle blowing the horn
with the strength of a giant.
So this part with the strength
of a giant, is a prepositional phrase.
Actually, it's two prepositional phrases,
because there's with the strength,
and then, of a giant.
What is a prepositional phrase?
It is a word chunk that begins
with a preposition.
So, with is a preposition,
of is a preposition,
and this entire thing, with
the strength of a giant,
is one prepositional phrase, altogether,
composed of two smaller ones.
And what's cool, is you can use
prepositional phrases in a couple
of different ways.
You can use them as nouns.
You can use them as adverbs.
And you can use them as adjectives.
So we've got two different examples here,
just even within this first sentence here.
So Danielle blew the
horn with the strength
of a giant. How did she blow the horn?
With the strength of a giant.
And so she blew the horn
with the strength of a giant.
So, with the strength of a giant,
this prepositional phrase is modifying
the verb blew.
You can really see, her hair's
being blown back just by the strength
of this (trumpet noise).
So this whole thing
together is being treated
as an adverb, but if we look
at the word strength, strength
is being modified by of a giant.
So this is a noun,
right, the word strength
is a noun, but this of a giant thing
is modifying it, so this part
is actually behaving as an adjective.
Kinda cool, right?
Let's look at some more examples.
To steal the queen's diamonds
would be a terrible crime.
This is actually something we'd call,
in addition to being a
prepositional phrase,
this is something we'd call an infinitive.
The verb to steal, when
it's presented like this,
in the to form never conjugates.
It's not affected by time, so it's
kind of infinitive and infinite.
But we are treating this whole thing
as a noun, right, because
to steal the queen's diamonds
is kind of all being considered one thing,
this big, old prepositional phrase,
would, right, to steal
the queen's diamonds
would be a terrible crime.
So, this prepositional phrase is acting
like a noun.
Let's try another one.
I don't know what that is,
I just made it up.
Let's pay attention to how
the prepositional phrase of glass
works in the rest of the sentence.
You know, what part of this
is it attached to?
It's not I of glass, or enjoy of glass.
It's the cathedral of glass,
and that means that this of glass thing
is describing cathedral.
A cathedral is a place or a structure,
so it's a noun, right, so if of glass
is modifying this noun, that would make it
an adjective.
So of glass here, this
prepositional phrase,
is behaving like an adjective.
Prepositional phrases
can be really powerful
and really elegant, and really cool.
Like in Hamlet, in the
"to be, or not to be"
speech, Hamlet describes death as
the undiscovered country,
from whose bourn,
no traveler returns.
And bourn is an Early Modern English word
meaning, like, boundary.
What Hamlet is saying in the soliloquy
is that death is a mystery.
People don't come back from it.
And I think that's like a really powerful
use of a prepositional phrase.
All of this is describing country
in a way that undiscovered is also doing.
So country is being
modified from both sides,
which is really cool, and it imbues
the word country with
a really strange power.
But, you have to be careful
because you can set yourself up
for a lot of ambiguity
with prepositional phrases.
You may remember this terrible joke
from Mary Poppins. One man says,
"I knew a man with a
wooden leg named Smith."
Other guy says, "But what was
the name of his other leg?"
It's silly, but it's
a good way to indicate
where confusion can arise
with prepositional phrases.
So I would say, generally,
that the solution
to a problem like this is to just put
the named Smith part
earlier in the sentence.
I knew a man named Smith
who had a wooden leg.
Maybe lose the prepositional phrase.
That solves the problem.
What I'm trying to say
is, prepositional phrases
are very powerful, but
you have to be careful
about how you use them, because
if you're not careful, you can create
confusion or ambiguity.
Anyway, you can learn anything.
Sorry for the terrible cockney accent.
David out.